so recently a friend of mine says to me
Derek you know your heaviest at night
before you go to bed and lightest in the
morning when you wake up okay but that
doesn't really seem to make sense of
course it does
overnight you're not eating anything for
like eight hours but you're still
burning calories so of course you'll be
lightest in the more yeah but where's
the mass going like how are you actually
losing particles you can't argue with me
I've weighed myself at night and the
next morning and I know it's true is
that after you went to the toilet no I
told you that has nothing to do with it
what do you have to disagree with
everything that anyone says you just
like arguing it's not that I like
arguing it's just that your statement
seems implausible I need some kind of
mechanism that would explain how you
could be heaviest at night and then
lightest by the morning why don't you
google it okay so I googled it and the
results were a little bit disturbing
I'll be three to five pounds heavier
during the nighttime hours and when I
wake up the next morning I'm back down
five pounds less I usually wear myself
in the morning I'm anywhere from three
to five pounds lighter odd an empty body
weighs less than a full one the force of
gravity also can weigh a person down
really Internet this is what we're
coming to but these are just people
posting on forums maybe people out on
the street are different so I'm gonna go
find some people in Perth and see what
they say but what time of day do you
weigh the most Oh what do you reckon
I suppose evening Tolman eaten too much
time yeah no time no time not just for
your bed yeah outside that as well
and lightest in the morning when you
wake up so the largest when you first
get out of bed so obviously if you keep
on eating and drinking during the day
one of these sort of people that way you
so wait but I weigh myself every single
morning of my life and I'm almost always
lightest in the morning when are you the
lightest first thing you wake up just
right when you wake up yeah you hop out
of bed yeah you were a light man yeah of
course the best way to settle this is
with an experiment so every night before
I go to bed I will weigh myself and in
the morning before I go to the bathroom
I will weigh myself again now in any
scientific experiment it's pretty
important to control your variables so
every time I go for my weigh-in I'm
wearing these exact clothes I know
pretty snazzy right the hotel staff here
have graciously allowed me to use their
scale but they told me I can't take it
to my room so I need to do the weigh-ins
at the concierge I'm going down for my
first weigh in Sunday night
we'll see what my weight is right now at
1:17 a.m. Russ
so seventy two point one zero kilos but
where does the mass go why are you
sleeping like how do you lose weight
while you're sleeping I think it
evaporates she sweats a lot
yeah I consider digesting at all so it's
kind of probably compressed out it's
true anyway does it go Bernie are we
burning it using it up whatever first
carbohydrate okay so where does the
matter actually go where does the weight
actually go it's transferred as energy
that your body uses says y'all like
science stuff like ATP are you saying
that we're converting matter into energy
yes that's one way of is that what kind
of it it uses up the matter yeah so
you're you just matters disappearing
from inside you give it
that's my question everything you put
into you doesn't all come out the other
end as well so you've got to use or
where does it come out what uses certain
parts of it to sustain you and let you
live all right so it doesn't think it
doesn't come out of you not all of it
it's a Monday morning I'm just gonna I
need to go to the bathroom so before I
do that I'm gonna go down for my
weigh-in
yeah please hello last night I weighed
70 2.1 kilograms let's see what away in
the morning
seventy one point nine say nine to five
kilograms I'm not really surprised my
mass is only changed by about 150 grams
it doesn't really surprise me but yeah I
don't think it's backing up my friends
theory so we'll have to do this a few
more times to make sure that these
results are valid the difference of
about 0.25 kilos 250 grams 72 point oh
five kilograms that's a loss of about
300 grams so it looks like every night
you lose about 250 grams which is pretty
similar to the amount that I've been
losing every day this week so how do you
actually lose weight as you sleep well
every night this week I seem to lose
about 250 grams I think about 150 grams
of that was water loss through sweating
and breathing out water vapor so where's
the other hundred grams going well every
time you breathe in your breathing about
500 milliliters of air but only about a
fifth of that is oxygen now
three-quarters of that oxygen you'll
just breathe out again but one quarter
of it gets replaced with carbon dioxide
now carbon dioxide compared to oxygen
has the extra mass of carbon on every
molecule and the mass of carbon released
in every breath is about a hundredth of
a gram I know that doesn't sound like a
lot but if you add it up sixteen breaths
a minute over eight hours it adds up to
about 100 grams every time you breathe
out you're losing weight because come on
never heard of that before then I don't
know if people don't talk about it
people don't think about it because I
think a lot of people think that matter
can be converted to energy that you can
take stuff and then it goes away somehow
in the metabolic process in that energy
process my point is the atoms are still
there that matter is still there you
need to get rid of it somehow
and some of it is is breathe that'd be
worse
so people were right when they said that
you are burning calories and that's
causing you to become lighter they just
didn't think about the exhaust the water
vapor and the carbon dioxide that you
breathe out so it may be the case that
your heaviest at night and lightest in
the morning but I think the real truth
of the matter is your heaviest after
your biggest meal and lightest after
you've gone to the bathroom it's after
lunch on Thursday so let's see what
difference a big meal makes I was
seventy 1.1 kilograms I'm now seventy
two point five five nearly added a kilo
and a half my lunch was nearly a kilo in
it so this morning when I woke up I was
seventy 2.1 kilograms but now I've gone
to the bathroom so I'd like to see what
difference that makes
seventy point six kilograms that is a
lot of mass that I've lost what is that
like 1.5 kilos 1.5 kilos
that's a lot of math